je suis là pour décrypter aussi la
presse people médias ce qu'on a vu dans
la semaine et pour éventuellement
apporter un petit correctif ok cette
semaine voici a fait en accroche de une
on le découvre ensemble fin de règne à
Miss France
fin de naissance et ouais ouais fin de
règles c'est-à-dire fin de règne pour
Jean-Pierre alors justement il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de subtilités dans le
papier en fait il est écrit qu'il a 74
ans donc il est trop vieux pour Alexia
la roche-joubert on parle d'un
Jean-Pierre sympathique mais dépassé et
que donc on lui a fait gentiment
comprendre qu'il va falloir qui qui
passe à autre chose
je vous invite à lire le papier qui est
extrêmement vache justement envers
Jean-Pierre Foucault il y a pas de de
d'info propre d'info brut c'est que des
des insinuations de ce genre là et moi
j'ai enquêté ah j'ai appelé la prod j'ai
appelé tous les informateurs vous avez
fait une enquête version TPMP ou une
vraie enquête de journaliste
de journaliste donc j'ai appelé tous les
gens qu'il fallait appeler à la prod
j'ai appelé tous mes informations
susceptibles de près ou de loin de
valider ou pas cette info et c'est archi
faux donc on verra bien Jean-Pierre
Foucault avec
la patronne actuelle non la
mais avec beaucoup de subtilités en
disant que
Jean-Pierre Foucault avait 74 ans qu'il
était dépassé qu'il était plus dans le
ton de l'émission et qu'il est l'heure
qui comprennent autre chose sauf que
c'est complètement faux tout ce que j'ai
eu au téléphone on démenti a commencé
par la prod Jean-Pierre Foucault je
crois était sur le plateau de Guillaume
ce matin pour expliquer que c'était
complètement faux et selon mes infos il
est pas content du tout tu penses
tu m'étonnes tout ton journal tu es viré
quand même sur ce que je sais non
seulement il va rester mais la prod a
peur qui s'en aille pourquoi pour une
raison très simple c'est que c'est le
gardien du temple c'est à dire que
Jean-Pierre Foucault c'est celui qui
conserve un peu le côté institutionnel
qu'on a un petit peu perdu avec le
départ de Geneviève de Fontenay
à l'époque Geneviève je crois qu'elle
avait essayé de remplacer Jean-Pierre il
y a quelques années évidemment ça ne
s'était pas bien passé donc là c'est
entièrement faux c'est bien lui qui sera
en place lui qui sera en place après
évidemment justement je vais aller dans
l'autre sens c'est-à-dire que la prod a
même peur qu'il s'en aille réellement
pourquoi parce qu'ils savent pas parce
qu'ils
et Foucault il a le loto c'est tout et
Miss France il a que ça donc lui il est
dispo donc voilà donc fausse info
des nouvelles de Madonna qui visiblement
à appliqué le proverbe on fait des
vieilles soupes avec des carottes
nouvelles visiblement alors je sais pas
[Rires]
il fait dans les vieux avec des carreaux
remplacé par qui vous voulez et les 40
poubelles s'appellent comment alors
les mauvaises langues disent aux
États-Unis mais un peu partout qu'elle a
trouvé son nouveau toy boy ah bah voilà
c'est la carotte on comprend pas par une
sorte de sextoy humain
alors il s'appelle André ça c'est avec
ou sans filtre parce que non attends
elle a quand même elle est jolie mais
elle a quand même elle a fait que
beaucoup de travaux quand même
tu parles de filtre Instagram ou tu
parles de travaux parce que les travaux
là alors là je parle de devis globale
entre entre le filtre et les travaux sur
la face je pense que c'est un mélange
des deux d'accord je pense qu'on est sur
un mélange des beaux garçons
alors est-ce qu'ils sont ensemble ou pas
alors oui enfin en tout cas voilà oui
non parce que c'est pas oui peut-être
ils sont ensemble oui ou non en tout cas
ils ont été vu se faire des gros câlins
dans un restaurant New Yorkais tous les
deux là on voit la photo ensemble ah
elle est d'accord il y a des témoins qui
ont passé c'est pas un câlin de ouf
encore quand même alors les témoins qui
ont un système à scène décrivent des
bisous et des câlins beaucoup plus
dans le cœur du sujet en fait
depuis un petit moment pourquoi parce
que voilà cette Une du magazine paper il
se coula [ __ ] d'anthologie dans une
scène un peu orgie
euh fait appel à la jeunesse c'est un
fusil récurrent et c'est lui qui
aimerait aborder évidemment certaines
personnes sur le plateau
âgée bien évidemment ça lui donne
l'impression la dernière info alors
celle-là alors celle-là m'intéresse
beaucoup parce que j'ai un point commun
avec le patron Cyril qui je le rappelle
est parti faire un petit match de paddle
et il va revenir dès que possible et
qu'il aura gagné puisque il doit gagner
les deux matchs pour être qualifié pour
ce phénomène cette personne c'est Margot
Robbie
je peux dire que Margot Robbie quand
même exactement Margot Robin une très
belle femme qu'on a on avait trouvé le
grand public la découverte dans le loup
de Wall Street ou alors dans la série
Paname ce qui connaissent qui est une
très bonne série malheureusement arrêtée
c'est une australienne a une trentaine
d'années elle est mariée depuis elle n'a
que 30 ans
quoi c'est ça que je veux vous dire
très jolie alors allons-y alors j'ai
j'ai deux mauvaises nouvelles la
première c'est qu'elle est mariée alors
ça pour moi ça me concerne pas du tout
mais ça reste une nouvelle enfin en tout
cas voilà elle est mariée depuis 2016
mais Brad Pitt est passé par là alors
lui celui-là dès qu'il passe tout très
passe le mec c'est un aspirateur à
gonzesse
[Applaudissements]
attendez moi je vous dis une chose très
importante et ça je suis très sérieuse
si vraiment Brad je connais un peu Brad
Brad et Margot sont ensemble s'ils font
des petits qui me regardent c'est qu'il
va être magnifique ah je pense qu'il
sera pas mal ouais ouais magnifique mais
je vous explique en fait ce qui se passe
alors explique-moi mais assez rapidement
ils sont dans un film ensemble qui
s'appelle Babylone
Babylone on a vu les premières les
premières images cette semaine alors
c'est un film
normal la transformation etc
et en fait
à la mostrade Venise Brad Pitt cette
semaine au bras de l'ananas qui joue
dans le film qui produit pour Netflix
mais les rumeurs les mauvaises langues
les mauvaises langues merci beaucoup
c'était Florian
[Applaudissements]